here's what would happen if algae took
over the oceans algae like phytoplankton
and seaweed create more than half of the
oxygen in our atmosphere and algae
consumes more carbon dioxide than trees
but it's not just good for cleaning the
air some of the world's biggest oil
companies are now researching whether
algae can be used as a sustainable fuel
source well that's good for the planet
as it would reduce our use of fossil
fuels and remove some contaminants from
the air but large amounts of algae in
the oceans can block sunlight from the
smaller organisms living underneath it
causing aquatic plants to die and once
aquatic plants are gone well the fish
the shellfish and other marine animals
that eat them would follow close behind
while we might want more algae to create
more oxygen and to eat more carbon
dioxide maybe it's better to farm it in
land-based facilities instead of adding
more to the oceans because